hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video
eingeblendet ich spiele heute google
also eigentlich das game aber das ist
quasi die google watch at google das
jetzt nämlich ein browsergame wo man auf
der linken seite ein bild eingeblendet
und einen namen von beispielsweise eine
person und darunter steht an die oft
diese person bzw
dieses objekt was dort abgebildet wird
geprügelt wird und auf der rechten seite
steht ein anderes bild das eine andere
person man muss sagen ob diese person
mehr oder weniger aufgebügelt wird wir
haben auf der linken seite muhammad ali
mit 335 millionen auf der rechten seite
nichts
was zum sind mit ein paar sekunden
später der google suche nach urteil sind
nicht neu sei
ich glaube man mäuse werden weniger auf
googles 3,35 millionen mal monatlich
denn da habe ich auch recht gehabt eben
hat war wie definitiv öfter
google-killer beide geschafft die
londons nation die apcoa
das könnte gleich viel sein ich bin
trotzdem hersagen mal weniger sind
vielmehr zwei punkte wir starten direkt
richtig gutes game hier rein in der tat
kaum hängt wird auf jeden fall öfter
135.000 monatlichen der briten in die
millionen genau sehen noch 1,2 millionen
eurovision gedenkt auch häufiger
gegoogelt nämlich weniger
wer erlaubt mir youtuber zu sein ein
tätowierer oder die auf jeden fall new
york oder wie auch immer das
ausgesprochen wird homophobie awi denke
ich auch häufiger gegoogelt und zwar
weniger häufiger meine das hat kann
diese kontraste eigentlich remake des
touratech alter hat aha definitiv mehr
als 100000 nämlich eine millionen dann
haben wir den gehweg
das ticket
das teilten unternehmen in den
vereinigen staaten die tickets verkaufen
ok cool wie soll ich das wissen wird ag
mehr als eine million mal gegoogelt ich
würde mal sagen jahren doch dieses
korsett ich weiß dass ich dieses game
mal auf meinem kanal gespielt haben habe
ich irgendwie über 20 geschafft oder wo
da war ich aber auch klug
und jetzt bin ich durch meine hunde
rapid 165000 monatliche google ein
physiologe definitiv mehr leute
interessiert sich doch merken
physiologen als runde also die
hunderasse spanier war super mario wird
glaube ich heute gegoogelt gerade weil
noch ein bisschen neu jetzt genau 13
millionen syrien zippel war glaube ich
weniger und 265.000 ziel bin ich mir
überhaupt nicht sicher ich weiß nicht
mal was genau ist ich würde trotzdem mal
sagen mehr über 150000 auch nicht so
viel da haben wir nämlich auch recht gut
mal carolina panthers ist glaube ich
irgendein football-team also auch 1,2
millionen zufrieden ist bin ich dumm
wenn ich so was nicht weiß wird sagen
weniger weil mir der begriff einfach
nicht bekannt dann haben wir auch wieder
recht gehabt miniatur schnauze auch
weniger attraktive hunderasse sogar
100.000 weniger kenner der auf jeden
fall in die millionen
disney keine ahnung wer das ist also
weniger geht auch nicht mehr in die
hunderttausende
die feier und war 550.000 dann habe
boris becker der wird auch
beim knicken ist mir aufgefallen dass da
gar nicht so oft gesucht werden können
weil er gar nicht mehr spielt trennen
who the golden share und social
enterprise haltet einfach eure presse
die ägyptischen pyramiden gegen jimmy
carter jimmy carter glaube ich mehr als
33.000 370.000 dann haben wir komplett
dieser beim klicken wie soll ich denn
dann alternativ wird 20 millionen mal
monatlich google maps mit den menschen
ok mit musik also musik ist geil folgt
mir auf soundcloud von cloud.com thescon
crafter ist aber auch ein relativ großes
unternehmen aber 20 millionen mal wie
das bestimmt nicht monatlich geholt
sondern drei millionen mal player auch
auf jeden fall weniger als drei
millionen mal monatlich damit nicht mehr
in die 50.000 rein anna konik glaube ich
ihm bekannte oder beste spielerin der
welt also auf jeden fall mehr bobby
ohren sagt mir nix ist sich nicht weiß
nicht wahrscheinlich ist es irgendwann
eishockeyspieler in amerika der übels
berühmte deswegen bin ich einfach mal
sagen mehr als anna kurnikowa und
weniger
ich bin diesmal wirklich
durchschnittlich versuche diesmal mehr
als das hilton hotel wie die weniger als
sieben millionen mal gegoogelt aber auch
schon eine millionen mal klingelt wird
mehrheit eine million mark
die letzten mal als wirklich immer mega
gut und es wird nicht eine million mal
gegoogelt dieses alter hey wie soll ich
das hinkriegen dass das ist
wahrscheinlich genau gleich viele hat an
die drei millionen ich würde sagen dass
dieses einfach mal mehr hat und war
genau gleich wie eduardo man ja otti hat
glaube ich weniger der islamische
startet wegen sogar noch 880 janet
jackson hat auf jeden fall mehr als 880
genau fast eine millionen einnahme
das ist schwierig freunde von dieser
entscheidung jetzt könnte das komplette
video hier ablegen mit einer video noch
länger geben dass sie direkt vorbei sein
wenn ich jetzt hin zu schaffen vor allem
man kann ja nicht mal schießen
ich meine wenn ich jetzt bei google
eingeben dann sehe ich nur wie oft es
ergebnisse gibt aber nicht nur auf das
monatlich gegoogelt wird also meine
damen und herren haram gegen challenge
ich bin mir überhaupt nicht sicher ich
würde aber trotzdem mal sagen
[Musik]